so Joe Biden has cemented his
frontrunner status in the Democratic
race for the US presidency he's
projected to win the big prize of the
night Michigan on a day of six primaries
billed as Super Tuesday to the former
vice president is also expected to win
in Mississippi and Missouri with three
more states now being counted it's
supposed to Joe Biden is already
dominant lead over Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders I want to speak to you
from Philadelphia where we announced our
campaign at the front end we did our
final announcement to all those who have
been knocked down all those have been
counted out left behind this is your
campaign just over a week ago many of
the pundits declared that this candidacy
was dead now we're very much alive all
right let's speak to gable Elizondo
who's in Detroit Michigan for as Detroit
of course was a big prize tonight in
this latest Democratic primary and some
crucial victories for Joe Biden how was
he able to do it
I was able to do it with a very
impressive coalition not quite frankly
black voters here in the state of
Michigan came out in overwhelming
support for Joe Biden that was very
clear he also based on exit polls seemed
to win a lot of working-class white
voters in Michigan as well which was
critical you add all of that up and
that's what you saw with this pretty
dominant win by Joe Biden here in the
state of Michigan you know you just
heard him say our campaign is still very
much alive I think he was understating
it there very much it's more than alive
he is without a doubt now be clear an
undisputed frontrunner in this
Democratic primary without a doubt and
we heard him in that speech in
Philadelphia just a short while ago
reaching out to Bernie Sanders
supporters telling them you know we have
a common goal and that is to defeat
Donald Trump in November will that
message be heard by Bernie Sanders
supporters I mean what is he likely to
do after what's been really not a great
night for him yeah it's been a terrible
night for Bernie Sanders this we're at
right now was supposed to be a Bernie
Sanders Sanders victory party it clearly
turned into nothing like that a lot of
dejected people here that were his
supporters and volunteers this was
supposed to be the night that Bernie
Sanders revived his campaign and
regained momentum
neither happened of course speaking to
some of his Bernie Sanders supporters
here they weren't much of a mood at this
juncture to talk about supporting Joe
Biden they still some of them say that
they still want to continue on they're
waiting to hear from Bernie Sanders to
see what's happening in the future what
he's gonna do
bottom line though I think it's gonna be
hard at least initially for Joe Biden to
win over a lot of Bernie Sanders
supporters but listen it's still it's
still very raw at this point the results
are still coming in but bottom line this
was an absolutely terrible night for
Bernie Sanders all right Gabe thank you
very much for that Gabriel is on to life
or is there in Detroit